[Música]
[Aplausos]
si hablamos de abogados digitales mucha
gente no sabe muy bien exactamente lo
que es si atendemos consultas por
internet oa qué nos referimos un abogado
digital es un abogado especializado la
legislación que regula las tecnologías
no solo internet
estoy aquí precisamente para hablar de
cómo esa legislación nos afecta pero no
no se preocupen no les voy a hablar de
artículos no voy a empezar a soltar aquí
un chorro de argumentos jurídicos que
les pueden dejar aburridísimos sabéis
que hablamos en castellano antiguo como
dice mi hermano y no es la idea
tenemos algo muy potente en nuestras
vidas que es internet y llevo más o
menos unos 20 años trabajando estas
materias lo que significa el derecho la
ley relacionado con la tecnología cuando
digo 20 años todo el mundo dice pero si
ni siquiera había internet pues sí claro
que había internet por supuesto en el 98
teníamos el messenger aquello tan tan
tan prehistórico fijaros whatsapp es de
2009 twitter es de 2006 justo el año en
el que yo empecé a trabajar con la
asociación de internautas han pasado
muchos años en tecnología cada año es
una auténtica era es muchísimo porque va
todo tan rápido que nos está costando
asumirlo como personas imaginaros para
la ley la ley siempre va por detrás de
la realidad debe ser así la ley tiene
que ser pensada reflexionada tiene que
ver el legislador que lo que va a
aprobar servirá para el futuro si
aprobamos todo rápido y pensando en el
caso concreto que tenemos hoy aquí lo
más probable es que cuando aparezca algo
nuevo nos sirva por lo tanto con la
tecnología la ley todavía tiene que ser
un poquito más reposada y tranquila que
tampoco se puede quedar muy atrás
hace 20 años como digo ya había redes
sociales empezaba a conocerse un poco
todo esto ahora todos tenemos red social
casi todo el mundo es difícil no estar
en una de ellas yo recuerdo cuando
empezaba a subir mis primeros posts post
imágenes comentarios y me planteaba
dónde iría a parar todo aquello quién lo
estaba viendo si me perjudicaría en el
futuro pero fijaros estoy hablando
y tecnología de unos añitos para acá me
voy a remontar al año 92 en el año 92 yo
estaba en el instituto en ponferrada y
recuerdo un día en el patio conversando
con los compañeros que uno de ellos
trajo una fotografía si en papel en
coraje y nos la enseñó era una chica que
en una de las excursiones haciendo el
tonto con sus amigos o con sus amigas no
sé se levantó la camiseta y se hizo una
fotografía esa fotografía ese papel
empezó a circular por todos los
institutos de abajo los tres que hay y
el de arriba también llegó
claro ahora vemos esa foto y pensamos
cómo circulaba esa foto no de mano en
mano
qué pasa hoy con las redes sociales
hacemos así con las fotos estamos
continuamente regalando copias de las
fotos a todo el mundo a mí me sorprende
mucho cuando se lo digo a algunas
personas y todavía me miran y dicen ah
es que es verdad yo no tú no le estás
enseñando la foto a tu familia cuando la
mandas al grupo de whatsapp estás
regalando una copia a cada uno de los
miembros de la familia cuando la subes a
twitter cuando las hojas a linkedin
cuando la subes a cualquier otra red
social de manera que esa conciencia a
pesar del tiempo que llevamos con redes
sociales todavía no la tenemos muy
asentada pero claro luego decimos bueno
está eso del derecho al olvido no si
todo eso que he subido lo quiero retirar
derecho al olvido
derecho al olvido no significa borrar
internet para nada solo significa que
google puede eliminar de los resultados
ese contenido que crees que te perjudica
y está relacionado con tu nombre de los
resultados no del hosting no del lugar
donde está alojada esa información y es
muy complicado primero yo hablaría con
el administrador de la página web dónde
está ese contenido que quiero retirar si
no me hace caso me iría directamente a
google oye por favor que no quiero que
esto se hagan los resultados y si google
no me hace caso me tengo que ir a la
agencia de protección de datos
y si no me hace caso me tengo que ir a
un juzgado de lo contencioso y si no me
hace caso tengo que seguir la línea
procesal hasta llegar a los tribunales
europeos
esto lo sé ahora que sé abogada que
llevo mucho tiempo trabajando y que
tenemos el derecho al olvido aprobado
con el reglamento pero yo tuve un
momento en el que dije ofelia ten
cuidado ten cuidado porque no es no es
algo muy útil subir toda tu vida a las
redes sociales tiene peligros porque
porque internet es un tatuaje
tú lo puedes poner intenta quitarlo si
se borrará algo pero siempre va a quedar
un rastro y nunca sabes cuando eso que
se ha replicado millones de veces puede
volver a salir en tu vida esto es la
reputación online esto es lo que nos
tiene que preocupar
una vez que tenemos ya la conciencia y
el cuidado
nos vamos a internet y en internet que
tenemos muchísimas posibilidades de
actuación y de interactuación y
muchísimos lugares donde dejar nuestros
datos personales bueno este es un cuadro
es ofelia muerta entre las flores de
john evertt miller es un pintor
británico y representa a la novia de
hamlet muerta en el río ella muere entre
las flores yo podría haberme arriesgado
a morir entre las redes pero no lo que
he hecho ha sido tener bastante cuidado
con que hacía con información personal
cuántos de ustedes se han burlado
apuesto alguna vez su nombre en google
para saber qué es lo que hay sobre
ustedes háganlo no es una cuestión de
ego es una cautela haganlo si van a
tener redes sociales lo primero que
tienen que hacer es pensar para que la
quiero para algo profesional para algo
personal para publicar fotos de paisajes
luego tengo que ver las posibilidad de
privacidad quiero que la vea todo el
mundo mis amigos quiero que la veas
solamente 45 personas whatsapp
whatsapp la foto de perfil de whatsapp
la tiene usted es privatizada para que
se la puedan ver sus contactos si yo
agrego un número al azar puedo ver su
foto
este tipo de cosas tengan mucho cuidado
porque si no acabarán como ofelia muerta
entre las redes sociales
no tenemos estas cautelas tendríamos que
volver a ese procedimiento que se puede
hacer muy complicado pero no es lo que
pretendemos pretendemos tener cuidado
cuidar nuestra reputación online
dosificar las redes dosificar la
información cuidado también con la
información de terceros a nadie se le
ocurre pedir permiso oye te importa que
suba esta foto
es que no se nos ocurre que es algo que
deberíamos hacer y además decirle la voy
a subir aquí porque porque quiero
retirarla ante el momento quieres que la
quite voy a revocar el consentimiento
etcétera
además cuando me abra una red social
otra precaución que hago que tengo es
mirar a ver si se pueden borrar los
contenidos mirar a ver qué pasa con todo
eso aún así no estoy exenta de riesgo
por tanto la mejor pregunta que os
podéis hacer es y si algún día llego a
ser presidente
como presidenta se avergonzarán de mí mi
familia mis amigos pues fijaros yo hoy
soy presidenta de la asociación de
internautas gracias a dios no hay nada
en google bueno algunas fotos que me
avergüence tenemos que tener mucho
cuidado ser o no ser que hacemos somos o
no somos digitales nos planteamos la
pregunta como se preguntaba a hamlet
crees que es muy difícil no ser digital
hoy muy difícil si no queremos estar en
el mundo por ejemplo para trabajar no
nos pongamos en las redes pero sí
necesitamos buscar trabajo en las redes
son fabulosas es muy útil pero cuánto
hay de esto en el futuro cuánta
tecnología va a ser nuestro futuro eso
hay cuánto del algoritmo para mirar el
mundo cuánto del humano no lo sé la
verdad es que no creo que llegue a ver
nunca que los robots nos dominen
afortunadamente creo que no veré una
réplica exacta sobre mí en un robot pero
nosotros tampoco somos dos más dos
cuatro necesitamos
el diseño basado en lo que es un humano
sus necesidades su dignidad a veces
intentamos con la tecnología poner
soluciones a problemas que no existen
esto lo ha dicho el supervisor europeo
de datos en relación con la
identificación facial para todo para
pagar el autobús para abrirte una cuenta
para abrir tu casa venga a tecnología
hoy el riesgo lo hemos valorado si la
tecnología no está pensada y reposada al
final es un atraso porque nos va a dar
más peligro más riesgo que utilidad la
comodidad no es utilidad la comodidad no
es eficiencia la tecnología sólo puede
ser útil al ser humano si es pensada en
términos de eficiencia coste beneficio y
si es pensado y reflexionada respecto a
los derechos humanos pero no yo no odio
internet para nada
adoro a internet es una herramienta
maravillosa nos traen las oportunidades
de lujo tenemos en nuestras manos la
posibilidad de ejercitar nuestros
derechos de una forma muy fácil tenemos
también un escenario maravilloso para el
libre desarrollo de la personalidad y
tenemos que reflexionar sobre hacia
dónde queremos ir tened cuidado con la
información que le dais a las redes
vigilar nuestra reputación online
y aprovechemos entre todos el siglo 21
para hacer las cosas bien gracias
[Aplausos]